jury selection begins this morning in
the federal trial of three fired
minneapolis police officers facing civil
rights charges in the george floyd case
thomas lane j alexander king
and two tao were all at the scene when
derek chovin killed floyd by kneeling on
his neck for more than nine minutes nine
minutes and 29 seconds chauvin was
convicted of murder in a separate state
trial last spring now he has pleaded
guilty to one of the federal charges
mola lange's at the federal courthouse
in saint paul where the other three men
will now go on trial
we're back in session and on the record
unlike the trial last spring where court
cameras captured derek chauvin as
prosecutors successfully made their case
this trial won't be broadcast former
minneapolis police officers thomas lane
jay alexander king and two tao are
charged with willfully depriving george
floyd of his civil rights attorney and
legal analyst joe tamborino what is the
defense's argument here the defense's
argument is twofold number one that they
did not willfully try to violate the
rights of mr floyd and secondly that
they had no part in what mr chauvin was
doing video of the deadly 2020 encounter
shows lane king and tau also at the
scene as chauvin kneels on floyd's neck
lane and king had been on the force for
less than a week
at the heart of this case is whether or
not the defendants could and should have
tried to stop chauvin in minnesota the
only person that has to render any aid
would be the good samaritan laws but
they don't apply to police officers
in minnesota the troubled relationship
between police and the community goes
beyond the death of george floyd just
last month former brooklyn center police
officer kim potter was convicted of
manslaughter in the shooting death of
dante wright and now we have these three
former officers it's quite a unique
confluence of all of these issues
dealing with police officer and
community relations
derek shovit could make an appearance at
this trial it is possible that he is
called to testify by either the
prosecution or the defense but at this
point it's unclear if either side will
do that if convicted these three
officers could face up to life in prison
tony
a lot of healing still needs to happen
there in minnesota and the search for
justice is part of it mola thank you
very much